my next guest sighs and gentlemen our
cast members on the hit HBO series Game
of Thrones please welcome William
Cunningham
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Applause]
thank you thank you well welcome to our
version of the view we've never done
anything like this is crazy so much to
talk about I like everyone here I'm an
insane fan of the show and it's real
it's a thrill
[Applause]
let's start with the first question we
talked about it in the last segment how
much do you worry about dying because
this show is such a big part of your
life they don't seem to care who they
kill when they kill them you never know
what's going to happen why don't we
start treating you tell us what you
basically are afraid of whether I'm
going to be naked again you have no idea
when you're going to be naked it just
you just turn the page and it says no
whether I have to go to a gym or not
[Laughter]
okay
mazie what about you do you try and ever
talk to the writers and get hints about
please tell me I'm gonna be okay this
season I start asking them and then I
feel like I'm being annoying I think
maybe I shouldn't ask them because I end
up dead quicker and then I turn to suck
it up to them and I'm like like you know
buy your drink or gonna go out some food
and they're like am I still being
annoying and I don't really know how to
get around the death thing but I'm doing
all right so you're doing okay so far I
got
now it has been occurred that the
writers and producers can be cruel and I
heard that Alfea they pranked you with a
script they they sent gave you a script
it was a fake script just to freak you
out tell us that story they did well I
just had no tact he was asking the whole
season whether I was gonna die or not
because we get the scripts in a way
where we get episodes 1 to 6 and then
we'll get the last four later on so I
asked them and they were just like
shrugging their shoulders sort of give
me that and then I I went on holiday I
had a three week break and and I've been
given this fake script where it was my
brand comes out and back of whole doors
back in Winterfell and says this is my
Winterfell not yours and stabs me in the
arts and so I thought it was a great way
to go I thought I'd be memorable and
they called me up when I was on a
holiday saying so how do you like your
ending do you like it knows that yes
cool thanks guys I'm like okay cool how
would you feel about being a zombie next
year right yeah I can do that okay how
would you feel about being a zombie with
absolutely no dialogue whatsoever you be
serious so yeah they can be kind of cool
with it not just kind of cruel that is
so none of that it was all BS they
didn't mean any of it and you still got
a job
John do you worry about getting pranked
I do but my worry is that we're under
estimating these guys and my worry is
that a lot of people have been prank
saying that they're gonna die my worry
is that you're gonna get 10 scripts and
that you're gonna have dynamite stuff
there's going to be there's gonna be
scenes with people you've never had
scenes before amazing narrative arc
you're gonna win Murray the hero of the
piece the day after please find script
amendments for episodes one to ten
changes made your honor in a single
frame of it is that possible could that
happen they could do that basically
whatever they want okay Sophie's answer
has been through a lot just so much
before this is not real folks
and II know sorry is real well you've
been through so much and before the
season even begins it feels like
unrelenting are you hoping that this
season things start to get a little
cheerier you can have one episode where
they're like that's a good cookie you
know why can't there be one episode but
they're like I had a good night's sleep
me too anyone get killed not a one oh
yeah and then resume next week yeah and
then we can all do like the villains
yeah I like that song it's original okay
I have to ask you something Maisie you
shot how meny for so long your character
was in filming and miserable kind of
cold conditions right were you jealous
that your account I got to be filming in
beautiful just look like a beautiful spa
true including Sofia number of the cast
members would disappear for like six
weeks and then come back and like yeah
we had a really amazing time in Croatia
it was so much fun and safe when show me
all the videos like all we were just
like playing in the ocean I really like
really really mean actually it hurt me
so when I was told that this year I was
going to create Croatia and so people
assumed I was totally thrilled not a
single ounce like of my body that felt
bad at all I was like you know I'm gonna
have an amazing time in Croatia without
you
nice the rough world Game of Thrones to
the right back more with the Game of
Thrones cast a sexy growl